Of the four pairs of logs down here, there are only two sets that we can
combine. Log base e of 4 plus ln of 5, and log base 10 of 5 plus log base 10 of
6. The reason that both of these can be combined in the product property is
because the bases are the same for the two logs we're trying to add. Here, we
have log base e and natural log. But we know that ln is actually shorthand for
log base e. So both of these actually have the same base and we can combine
them. The same is true for the logs down here. Log base 10 of 5 and log base 10
of 6, have the same base. Since remember, that's the number that goes down here
as the subscript of log. The two remaining choices can't be combined because
the bases of the logs we're trying to add are different. Here we have log base
10 and natural log, which, again, has a base of e. 10 and e are not the same
number. So, we can't combine these. The same concept applies here. We have a
base of 2 and a base of 10, so we can't use the product property.